how we dress is our way of presenting to
the world who we are without explanation
from the clothing on our bodies to how
we wear our hair fashion is not just
about trends
it's representative of our cultures and
one of the truest forms of
self-expression
so we're looking back and re-examining
what fashion looks like
the way i dress makes other people smile
and say oh the green lady i think people
really like the belief that you like
something enough to carry it through
long nails have been a part of my life
practically all my life every week i go
for four to five hours to get my nails
done and when i leave out of there it's
like okay my nails look beautiful i feel
beautiful and i'm revived i'm charged
let's go
for us church hats are not just hats
they are crowns and when a woman puts
one on she becomes a queen
you look your best and you feel your
best when you put on a hat it gives you
height and it gives you power
[Music]
but
there's a lot of young african and
nigerians that are beginning to embrace
the snicker culture because i think
sneakers are a form of expression for
most people what you wear says a lot
about who you are
[Music]
[Music]
i'm an anomaly in this scene for sure
cross stitch is a antiquated form of
stitching traditionally done by your
grandma
i create custom one-of-a-kind crossfit
jackets for chicago's creative class i
fell backwards into it it came very
naturally to me and so it's truly truly
a passion project
from childhood i had a vision to be a
unique person in the world
i like to stand out i
wear only red and white
when i go out hundreds of people are
watching me public is always talks about
me i like to be unique
it makes me more happy at least people
are smiling at me
[Music]